The Joe Rogan Experience were you aware
of how twisted the system was before you
started doing this litigation before you
started going over the the peer-reviewed
papers and finding out where they did
were you aware of how the system was set
up it came in two stages so as I after I
finished my residency in Family Medicine
I did a Robert Wood Johnson Fellowship
for two years and and that was a
wonderful uh training in epidemiology
and research design and statistics so
that that's where I got these skills
that I came back and Drew on but family
medicine is very hard in an academic
environment the the purpose of
Fellowship was to train academics in
Family Medicine to increase The Prestige
of Family Medicine which seems like a
good idea but family medicine is very
difficult in an academic environment
because they're the family Doc's a low
man on the totem pole in the hospital
and all the Specialists
um Specialists often don't treat them
with the respect they just serve and I
decided that my calling was to go be a
doctor in a smallish town and I did that
for 20 years but I had this Robert
Johnson Fellowship training always in
the back of my mind and as we got
through the late 90s it became clear
that the drug companies were influencing
what was in the journals and then the
drug do you remember the drug vioxin
arthritis drug I have a friend who had a
stroke after taking vioxx yeah
so
it yeah I I got a letter from a mother
whose child died 14 17 year old child
died
from taking vioxx eight samples of iox
um but vioxx came along and there was an
article in New England Journal
that Merck had sponsored and it said it
was safe and was advantageous not
because it was any more effective but
because it reduced the risk of serious
GI problems
and then there was another article in
the New England Journal of Medicine that
fessed up to cardiovascular problems
but the review article said
this may be due to the play a chance
because there were only 70 events and
such a small number of events is uh
subject to statistical variation
and I knew
that that was crazy because there were
only 53 serious GI events which was the
whole reason for selling this two
billion dollar a year drug was that it
was safer on the GI tract and there were
only 53 events it was an
anti-inflammatory right it was like yeah
exactly so the idea was that that was
better than non-steroidal
anti-inflammatories exactly because it
because it didn't uh upset the stomach
the same way and this the science was
elegant and it might have worked but it
didn't
um and in changing that balance it made
the blood more likely to form clots
um the physiology was a little more
complicated than just stomach or no
stomach and is something like this the
the issue is the size of the trial
because you could have 10 people and
none of them can have a problem but you
could have 10 000 people and you could
have quite a few problems so you have to
make this this study as large as
possible so you get all this biological
variation between human beings where
different things affect different people
in different ways that's part of it and
you can have a study of 8 000 people
where you leave out three heart attacks
and you flip the statistics and claim
that there's not a cardiovascular risk
okay so they just it was fraud it was
fraud and you couldn't tell the fraud
from the article in the New England
Journal they Merck had submitted this
data to the New England Journal and they
did what peer reviewers do which is not
have the data but make sure that the
article makes internal sense they
publish the article and then this review
article came along
and they gave a little bit more insight
into the cardiovascular problems but
they blew it off as the play a chance
because they're only 70 events and that
was crazy and at that point I was
sitting in my office at lunchtime
reading taking a break between sessions
reading this article
and I said that's it I got to find out I
got to figure this out there's something
so wrong going on here that it's beyond
my comprehension
so um an article was published in Jama
two weeks later that had a footnote that
led to FDA an FDA website that had
enough data to see that Merck had been
fraudulent about the heart attacks
and when I saw that I said I'm going to
leave practice and I'm going to figure
this out
and I worked for two years on a book
called overdosed America it was
published in 2004
and it had the viac story in it
and uh a week after that book was
published viax was pulled from the
market it wasn't my doing
another study had Merck's Merck had done
a second study that showed the same
thing that the risk of strokes and heart
attacks and blood clots was doubled and
at that point they had a bullet because
they were hiding the data on this first
study now the second study came along
and it was clear that The Jig was up for
them and how long have they been
prescribing and distributing vioxx at
that point uh it came out in May of 99
and that was September of 2004. wow so
25 20 between 20 and 25 million
Americans had taken vioxx and between 40
and 60 000 Americans had died
from the cardiovascular consequences of
vioxx as in the same ballpark as the
number of Americans who died in Vietnam
died from taking this drug
that was no more effective at treating
arthritis or aches and pains than
non-steroidal anti-inflammatories
and caused forty to sixty thousand
deaths and what was the punishment for
Merck
Merck um there were 27 000 plaintiffs in
the litigation and they were awarded 4.7
billion Merck sold 12 billion dollars
worth of viox in the four and a half
years it was on the market
um so they
paid the plaintiffs 4.7 billion and the
Department of Justice fined them a
little bit under a billion dollars
but nobody went to jail
well not only that they're still making
profit that's a profit
they Merck uh excuse me
um vioxx
they probably made a small profit they
probably they took in 12 billion they
had research and development costs
um and marketing costs and all
manufacturing costs so a small profit of
what a billion dollars maybe they made a
billion isn't that wild you can make a
billion dollars from lying Joe it's even
after being it's crazy and the Merck's
Chief scientist saw the data from that
first study where the 300 texts were
omitted and there's a there's a uh an
email that the Wall Street Journal
published uh from March 9 2000 when they
opened up the data on that and the email
I'm paraphrasing but the email said
something like it's a shame but the
cardiovascular effect is there
but
the drug will do well and we will do
well oh God
that's written down it's written and no
one goes to jail for that no he's I mean
that that is insane I mean imagine any
other thing that you do that's fraud
that causes 40 000 deaths between 40 and
60. imagine any other thing any other
thing that you would sell imagine if
that was like Oreo cookies or you know
whatever
it's unheard of it's unheard of and
that's why it continues foreign
because there's not adequate oversight
there's no consequences there's
consequences but there's slaps on the
hand but yeah you know usually when the
fines are announced by the Department of
Justice the stock goes up because the
shareholders are happy to have this
burden off